how often Magnus fall for the opening
trap well in this video you are going to
witness the latest one in the 13 round
of the 2023 World Blitz Championship
Magnus had black pieces and we have
sveshnikov opening on the table where
after the move a for Magnus should have
avoided the Trap by playing A6 kicking
this Knight
immediately instead he decided to Castle
quickly with Knight G6 and after A5 he
played Bishop to E7 only to find the
rude shock Bishop E3 and after this by
force black is losing the pawn in the
game Magnus decided to Castle and Sack
the pawn which is the best option
however in case if you're wondering why
not A6 now the answer is very simple
white will play Bishop B6 and then
Knight C7 check which almost getting a
complete winning advantage in the
opening later on Magnus do manage to
lost the game and it shows that even
world's best can be tricked in the
opening stage